say this something like this happens
right
you're like
you're leaving work okay okay
and
things got compromised out in the world
you were at work you're doing a podcast
episode or something and like things
just kind of hit that level where it's
like maybe a couple police precincts
have been taken over just by vandals and
crazies like like the pendulum starting
uh
things are getting like a wall right and
then everything the purge right so
you're driving home you're getting
[__] cam haynes is sitting you have
[__] a thousand hammers you know what
i'm saying like you're getting all of it
everybody's just texting you you know
jacob's like i'm i'm not even waking up
tomorrow for work i'll be up all you
know i'm just gonna be up at 4 30 right
like everything's all what do you do
like how do you this is the end this is
when it's like all right joe rogan you
hear you know what i'm saying you hear
it just comes from god or from something
like a strong wind with a [__]
with a voice box in it it's like this is
it this is the apocalypse you're leaving
work this is it i guess you have to
respond to each individual situation
um on
you it's like each thing would be unique
like if someone trying to break in your
house is someone trying to
rob your
you know someone trying to break into
your car while you're driving okay so
you have an hour you have kind of an
hour right
we'll give you 90 minutes you have 90
minutes to kind of get before that
you're going to start to feel some
pressure
what do you do
i don't know i guess load up some
magazines oh i'm [__] but i'm
wondering what do you do you know that's
what i would do i'd probably load up
some magazines okay into what
into guns okay okay okay yeah i see i
don't know if you [__]
no periodicals
like sports illustrated
i mean like an ar
this guy's taking information with him
into a bunker
i'm reading time magazine
yeah dude
i'm like i just see joe with as many
copies of field and stream as you can
[__] live well you could use those
magazines as like protection you stack
enough of them okay so each other okay
now you're thinking slow bullets down
okay but say like you pick up your
family or something do you guys stay do
you have a bunker
i don't currently but this conversation
is making me want a bunker yeah yeah
i've wanted a ranch for that very reason
like if [__] goes completely sideways it
would be great if there was a place with
water and food we got you got your water
you got your food like on the property
okay what about if you're kind of in a
city or you're in like a um
like what's maybe a business or
something you'd hold up in you think is
viable a business that i'd hold up in it
would have to be some sort of fortified
establishment like the mall
no
no you'd have to get something that
you could defend dude the mall
yeah the mall
i think you'd have probably like think
of all you could hide in the [__]
macy's behind all the hiding cinnabon
behind the counter yeah yeah
just squeeze the frost into your mouth
and [__] pumping shells it would be a
good excuse to eat that food because
like i got to eat something and that
stuff will keep because a lot of that
stuff has like all the um preservatives
preservatives in it so you'd have that
you'd have mannequins in there think
about that you could set up like a um
like a mirage right right right like a
fake sort of situation yeah where people
would think that but you're behind that
yeah
so the mall i think could be good
yeah i've been thinking about that
um
i would go to the mall really yeah the
mall
yeah because nobody's at the mall
anymore but the dumbest people are at
the mall they're gonna [__] it up for
you
they gotta go they're gonna go the
russians are here guys
okay shut the [__] up i'm pretending to
be a mannequin
i'm like hey
give me a medium
have you ever been in a riot like a riot
type situation
no i was at bay to breakers one time on
mushrooms in
san francisco though
what is beta breakers what is that it's
like a bunch of people they're like
racers they're like um
they raced in the street you know what
kind of racing um just for long distance
the canyons always win it yeah running
okay yeah running racing
so it's a bunch of those folks bay two
breakers i thought you were saying beta
breakers yeah bay two breakers
i thought he was saying that too so i
typed in
oh no beta breakers i think is a little
different bay two breakers yep so that's
the run yeah so that's the run and you
can just get in costumes and just be in
the be in it it's like oh like the dude
is dressed up like a pink monkey yeah
how weird is that he's at the front oh
mcdonald's they dressed up like ronald
mcdonald yeah so people just do all kind
of costumes oh interesting and we ate a
bunch of shrooms out there and kind of
commandeered this water table there was
a water table that had kind of been left
on uh unattended what is a water table
just a table with a bunch of cupcakes
on it okay so we got over there and
people were running you know they're
going and we started telling people that
the water was for asian people only
right
but we are
crying laughing because people are
running they can't stop they're trying
to make a time so for some people like
bro it's asians only and it was like
[Laughter]
and then asian people were all excited
you know and we kept dousing them up
dude we were [__]
i would take pictures with like uh
people and i'd have my [__]
nuts hanging out the whole time though
it wasn't yeah we were actually pictures
of people here
how old are you at the time
i don't know probably 28.
[Laughter]
and people like hey let's get a picture
together so we get it and i just slip
that bag out there baby that [__] gum
holster
you know what i'm saying
people do you think more people are
related than we realize that there's
more that that's sometimes why people
get um like
born with certain deficiencies and stuff
like that like down syndrome and all
that because
more
down syndrome
because more people are related
yeah yeah i know i got stuck in an
elevator one time i was at mardi gras
and uh we were in there for like 17
minutes and some dude there's two girls
and there's like nine people it was like
a busy day at mardi gras
i'm there with nobody josh kelly is a
musician he's playing we take this
elevator and like nine of us get stuck
in this elevator for like maybe an hour
but you can hear mardi gras going around
we're like how long are we going to be
in here and we're in there in a little
while and some guy goes to two girls in
there he goes don't worry nobody in here
is gonna rape y'all that's what he said
and suddenly like everything in there
just changed we're like nobody's even
thinking about that [__] you know how
big is this elevator it was probably
honestly i bet it was almost as big as
this table
big out big elevator yeah maybe two feet
smaller on that end maybe one foot so
not so big elevator yeah and some guy
kept trying to just pull the doors open
as hard as he could
and how many people are in there with
you i would say seven people seven
people and two of them are girls yeah
boy
suck to be them after that idiot has to
say that yeah yeah dude because you have
to think about that yeah
no one's gonna rape you like what the
[__] man imagine and if he's not
thinking about raping them then you
think he's gonna be thinking about you
know did anybody tell him to shut the
[__] up uh people just said calm down
calm down
you know it was but it was just
interesting how it escalated like you
know things started to escalate
um
you work
you've worked so long at ufc do you feel
like um
that and i've watched your pace over
there i remember when i did a show with
you in atlanta and then we went to
we did a show the night before then we i
was sitting behind you and so like you
you guys are commentating and then you
go right up into the ring and you come
right back down and you commentate again
i mean it was like watching like a
it just seemed like a lot like this is a
lot you know like you have to have a
real pace for it it's a real job yeah
you have to have energy for sure it blew
my mind yeah it's like and you're doing
it for six hours yeah and i sit down for
six hours and i try not to pee which is
lucky that i have good experience doing
the podcast because i'm used to like
holding my piss for three hours but
that's about my limit so i always have
to pee at least once or twice ride that
bag baby you know i like riding that bag
hard though sometimes like also i'm
drinking like monster energy drinks
sometimes which are like piss magnets
yeah
yeah yeah they're delicious but they
make you want to pee make you want to
beat your wife too dude i've seen a lot
of dudes drinking monster that you know
they're going home to punch
i don't know if the monster is the cause
of it i think there's probably other
other factors well i'll say this it's
the beverage of choice of some of those
gentlemen
[Laughter]
i'll say that do you thought it was rock
stars
maybe it used to be
it's a great job man i love it i look
forward to it every time i look forward
to it this weekend i'm doing this
weekend in dallas i'm pumped oh nice i
don't know who's fighting on that one
it's amanda nunez too yeah versus
juliana pena was that the first one
yes who knows what's happening in that
room and halle berry was there at the
first one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
was coolly barry's a big fan she's there
all the time yeah that was a cool sport
yeah jared leto was there he's neat he's
always there too yeah yeah he loves it
it's always uh i mean it's exciting man
you know who's a big fan of it now mark
zuckerberg he's a big fan of him really
yeah yeah yeah he loves it he got like
super addicted to it he's training now
he's doing jiu jitsu oh wow yeah good
for him they should make him fight other
owners of things who do you think he
would fight
bezos
peter's a little older
kind of cruel to make him fight paid he
might [__] bazel who could he get in
again
somebody that i put all my money on elon
you teaching martial arts yeah he'd
figure out a way to [__] you up yeah
yeah he's a fish and he just had like
nine kids in a month i heard on twitter
how [__] efficient is that
i think he's doing it through in vitro
fertilization i'm sure he jerks off into
a fedex tube and he mails it to these
ladies
i thought about that i thought about
having a kid via like a machine or
something you know you think that's the
way to do it i think because i was
thinking about having a child with a
friend of mine a guy or a girl a woman
okay
i just want to let you know what you can
and can't do